merci Yenko dit le drapeau des
orangistes toujours rassemblé sur la
Place de l'Indépendance soutien à un
homme fatigué à l'intérieur du Parlement
victorenko dont le visage semble sêtre
encore dégradé voici un an jour pour
jour le visage du même homme qui a 50
ans avait diton le physique d'un Clinton
ukrainien avant après avant le 5
septembre 2004 après date fatidique date
d'un étrange dîner avec le chef des
services secrets ukrainien 5 jours après
le candidat de l'opposition ukrainienne
était hospitalisé dans cet hôpital privé
de Vienne une clinique de luxe ore entre
autres un médecin ukrainien le docteur
Nicola corpan en blouse blanche à
l'image un proche de Yenko alors
empoisonné ou non oui dit ce matin le
docteur corpan au très sérieux quotidien
anglais Times non dit cet après-midi le
même homme accompag C il est vrai de son
directeur le
professeur H politique la réalité
médicale semble plus implacable je cite
pour l'instant aucun diagnostic
incontestable n'a pu être délivré pas de
preuve mais cet après-midi à Vienne le
professeur zimf a fait une importante
révélation il y a de jours à Kiev dans
la plus grande discrétion une nouvelle
prise de a eu lie le prélèvement aurait
pris la direction d'un laboratoire
spécialisé en matière de dioxine un
poison quelque part en Europe
continentale nous cherchons dans cette
direction nous ne savons pas encore s'il
y a de la dioxine et la réponse du
laboratoire devrait nous parvenir dans
de jours 48 pour connaître la vérité VO
c'est sur les épaules de ces médecins
que repose en partie l'avenir politique
de
l'raine